contemple même eu les mots et disparaît
tout vendredi le blogueur rêve badaoui a
appelé sa femme et sa fille d'art mais
cette fois ci pour lui annoncer ce
qu'elle souhaitait le plus au monde il
est libre pour moi c'est c'est bien
c'est bien jusqu'à maintenant c'est pas
voter at elle tant parce que j'aimerais
soit 10% pour ça mais ça c'est les pour
mieux les premières étapes ses livres
ses livres
il n'a pu confirmer à sa femme s'il
pourra quitter l'arabie saoudite ce qui
lui est présentement interdite mais
l'espoir est bien réelle on n'avait pas
sauté en cours et dans la maison fait
c'est vraiment beaucoup d'émotion et lui
dire qu'il vienne ici qu'on l'attend un
piqué ça va pas et l'empiré venir avec
nous
1 376 yens vendredi
la communauté sherbrooke étaient réunis
pour demander sa libération
des cris de joie ont rapidement fusé
la nouvelle de sa libération a
rapidement trouvé écho sur la scène
politique et premier ministre du québec
françois legault a réagi sur twitter en
espérant qu'enfin des enfants puissent
retrouver leur père sauts de joie
moi je n'oublierai jamais à taboye une
motion déposée par le bloc québécois
proposant d'accorder la citoyenneté
canadienne arrive badaoui a été adoptée
à l'unanimité l'été dernier les
pressions pourraient s'accentuer
elle n'a jamais lâché
aujourd'hui les libérer le gouvernement
et les mains les outils nécessaires pour
discuter pourparlers avec ce régime là
et je badaoui a assez payé amnesty
international se réjouit de cette
première bouffée de liberté pour ipad ah
oui mais prévient déjà qu'il faudra
multiplier les efforts pour en arriver à
des retrouvailles
blida pour que l'interdiction de sortie
du pays soient levés qui peut s'être
réuni avec sa famille le plus tôt
possible ici marie blaquart canada à
sherbrooke
[Musique]